PRESIDENT TO FAIL AT ALL COSTS.
WE WILL EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS IN A
VERY IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT.
IT IS NOW DAY 352 OF MUELLER'S
WITCHHUNT.
STILL ZERO EVIDENCE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE COURAGEOUSLY
STANDING UP TO THIS TOTALLY OUT
OF THE CONTROL WITCHHUNT IN WHAT
IS THE SINGLE BIGGEST BEATDOWN I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE BY A
JUDGE.
CAMPAIGN CHAIR MANAFORT'S
CHARGES GOES BACK 13 YEARS.
A U.S. DISTRICT JUDGE NAMED T.S.
ELLIS III UTTERLY REBUKES THE
INVESTIGATION AND TELLING A
MEMBER OF MUELLER'S TEAM, "YOU
DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
MR. MANAFORT.
YOU CARE ABOUT INFORMATION
MR. MANAFORT CAN GIVE YOU TO
LEAD YOU TO MR. TRUMP AND AN
IMPEACHMENT OR WHATEVER."
THE JUDGE WENT ON TO SAY, "YOU
WANT MANAFORT TO SING."
AND JUDGE ELLIS ALSO CLAMMING
THE SCOPE OF MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION, SAYING, "WE DON'T
WANT ANYONE WITH UNFETTERED
POWER."
AND THE JUDGE EVEN MOCKED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL SAYING, "WE SAID
THIS WAS WHAT THE INVESTIGATION
WAS ABOUT, BUT WE'RE NOT BOUND
BY IT.
AND WE WERE LYING."
A FEDERAL JUDGE JUST CONFIRMED
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN SAYING
ON THIS SHOW FOR MONTHS.
THERE IS NOTHING MUELLER WILL
NOT DO TO MALIGN THIS PRESIDENT,
EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT TRUMP,
NOT THESE OTHER PEOPLE.
DURING A SPEECH THE PRESIDENT
WAS GIVING AT THE NRA, HE
REACTED TO THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NONE OF THAT INFORMATION HAS
TO DO WITH INFORMATION RELATED
TO THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
COORDINATION AND THE CAMPAIGN OF
DONALD TRUMP.
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO.
IT'S FROM YEARS BEFORE.
THEN, HOW DOES THIS HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
CAMPAIGN, THE JUDGE ASKED.
LET ME TELL YOU, FOLKS, WE'RE
ALL FIGHTING BATTLES, BUT I LOVE
FIGHTING THESE BATTLES.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>>IT'S A BATTLE OVER THE RULE
OF LAW, EQUAL JUSTICE AND
APPLICATION OVER THE LAW.
IT'S A BATTLE OVER THE